good morning
so we we managed to get ubuntu working
with screens
that's that's impressive that's always
really hard
so today i'll be talking about some of
the
approaches you can take modularity for
building fronts and apps
and these approaches are agnostic from
like your particular choice of package
manager
guy has done a great ton of work with
jspm these techniques are going to work
just fine
with any good package manager and the
fact is volkswagen was great
it showed exactly what to do have a huge
tree
and have like 120 kilobytes of
javascript at the minimum
that's definitely like the way to go
so a little about me i'm reynolds
i've done a lot of stuff in node and in
the browser with npm
sometimes i think you have a little bit
of an addiction to open source
i've written at least like 100 modules
targeted at the browser
and this approach has been working great
for me
so we'll go over a bit of an overview of
the things i'll be talking about
so the first thing is like how did you
get started with modules
how do you use them guy pretty much
covered this already so
we'll just blaze through that the second
part is
what does it mean to offer small modules
and why
what are the benefits of like offering
these small
micro modules instead of offering like
big libraries or larger things
we'll take a look at a similar example
to what guys showed
which is just you know you can embed
things with css and assets and like
self-contained and all just work
and i will talk a bit about
how you can build your own
flexible framework for modules i'll talk
more about what i mean by framework
later cool so
some of the tools of the trader i'll be
discussing and i've used
um these are these you don't need these
you need anything that's equivalent
um let's let's get um a bit of a
quizzing and questions going who's his
well everybody's already heard of npm
because it was mentioned
who's here has used npm before that's
that's a good number what about
browserify
um who here's heard too much about unix
philosophy and how great it is
okay okay cool so
quick recap npms please put javascript
now one of the really cool things about
npm is
it's so easy to publish you go and write
some code
and you hit npm publish it's done
no waiting no no gatekeepers
no nothing the other thing that's really
nice is avoiding dependency hell how
npm has managed to get nested dependence
to work such that
you don't run into version conflicts
which is kind of important because
as you start doing modular things you're
going to have
multiple things at different versions
and you don't want to have to think
about conflicts or worry about that you
want to just work
browserify you can write common.js it
bundles it into one file
and everything just works it's great now
one of the things i do recommend
checking out is this browser by handbook
substack road of last week so it's like
substance browser of a handbook and he's
written like
pages and pages and pages and pages
about really
really there's too much there it's too
much
and the last thing i mentioned is that a
lot of my inspiration comes from
some unique philosophies this one is the
quote about modularity
and to sum it up it suggests that you
should use
small things and connect them together
and
one of the biggest things it says is
the part that's really important here is
like
this this part here as you start using
small things
they can be replaced you're gonna run
into
oh that was a mistake i shouldn't
have used that thing nothing was
terrible
the other thing is i have a bad habit of
feeling like i want to be able to
maintain
and read all my dependencies because i
have a feeling that those officers are
going to get hit by buses
or they're just gonna abandon stuff on
github
which happens that happens so much um if
something is small
it is a lot easier to be able to be
comfortable that no matter what happens
i can continue working with this
it also helps if it's not written in the
coffee script but that's just a personal
thing for me
okay cool so when using modules
why so
one of the big things that i love
about this approach is i get to just
pick the best everything
like i don't have to make a compromise i
don't have to pick a large thing and go
like well
i like eighty percent i just won't touch
the other twenty percent
i don't have to deal with that i get to
really drive
also drive my architecture and my design
and application
around what i wanted to be rather than
what some of the tools i pick off the
shelf are telling me how
telling me to do you use what exactly
what you need no more
so that lower on kilobytes in theory
sometimes doesn't work out in practice
and lower on complexity
so just
knowing that you don't have these really
large things your dependency tree
you don't have to worry about them you
don't have to
worry about upgrading them
whenever i used some of these big
libraries
or whenever a new major version came
around
i had to spend a couple of days updating
my app
with these small modules the scope of
what you have to deal with is way
smaller
and you can upgrade them more easily and
obviously
freedom like freedom to switch
whenever you find something that works
better for application
whenever i build an application i don't
know what it's going to be
like i have an idea in my head of how
it's going to work
but it's always wrong
i need to have the freedom to be able to
adapt
and move as i start to understand my
application better
so modules are great but they're hard to
find
like when you start out you don't know
where they are you don't know which ones
to use
which ones are good which ones are not
good
and honestly one of the best approaches
to figuring out what the good motors are
is you go and talk to somebody like you
talk to them isc talk to them on twitter
you talk to them at a conference
failing that npm search does wonders
i'm going to try and use npm search
later and see where it actually gives me
what i want
i hope it does and then the last part is
there's a whole bunch of these
groupings and collections on github
and other websites where people have
gone and like
thrown small modules together in like
one bucket
it's basically like a list it's like a
wiki page
and these actually work wonders and you
can kind of see
what's worked for other people some
other people claim that if you're gonna
like build
stuff with webgl like all these
things do good stuff
i don't know anything about webgl but if
i wanted to try and start there
i'd basically go that and in fact when
you think about it
looking at one of those things it's like
talking to the person who wrote it
that person's like telling you what the
good things are
and there's a whole bunch more like
examples there's a whole
voxel level db and streams community of
people making lists of
much else and this is where i write
code yay all right so let's let's
actually
get started and show
what it looks like no no this one
show what it looks like to
write code
with open two shells
yeah show what it looks like to write
code
with these modules so
go in here we'll create a new little
file
yay so the first thing i have here is i
have html file for my little demo
that just has some css because css is
i i don't want to talk about how to
manage css that's difficult
um it has n bundle so it has um the
bundle we're going to load so we're
going to have to create a bundle
and we'll start here but building a
thing
so i want to go and build a little
piece of dom and i'm not going to do it
by hand so i'm going to try and search
for module
that allows me to create a new dom
element
and then hopefully npm comes back with
useful results
don't all right and there's a module
called new element
in the list that hopefully does what i
want so
i open docs for it by using the npm docs
command
and go over to the browser and say
create new elements
put some html in it and some like
templating fantastic that's exactly what
i wanted
so i want diff
box put some text in that
close to div some
text oh just come
so we just require the mod to the top
yada yada
it works great and then we want to grab
the container
so again i would search for stuff but
i'm going to skip that step because npm
search is a bit slow
we're going to grab the container by id
grab id
and then we need to append stuff so
we'll grab a painted pen stuff
and we'll depend box container
and the box that works just great
so one of the first things you might ask
yourself is okay cool
i could have done this jquery this is
really not that hard
if you use larger libraries for example
jquery here
you're going to be stuck with the
interface they have you're going to be
stuck with
whatever design decisions they've made
and their interface and the features
part of the box now pending as trivial
you don't really
mean stuff for that by id goes directly
to
document like element by id which is
significantly faster than querying with
like a
hash container and this new element
thing it kind of looks like how you
would build
elements with jquery except it has
string interpolation built into it
and i don't know about you guys but i
don't like concatenating strings
manually when i can use string
interpolation
so by picking these small modules i have
the freedom to use a nicer api
i have the freedom to like say
actually the api this other big thing
gave me the box is not good enough i
just want to go and like
pick a different one and if there's a
bug in this guy i'll just like
throw it away and use a different module
because there's another five to do
exactly that
so we'll um go here
press if i demo spin it two
bundle
and then we'll open
demos in the spinner yeah
so that failed horribly because reasons
oh yeah i know i know why i made the
text call up white
and then css because so that's a great
idea white and white right
um so let's finish writing the rest of
the code here
so this demo is just gonna be a little
circle
that spins around so to do this
animation
i'm going to use a request animation
frame loop
increment this counter render the box
in like the new location for the
animation
and then loop again
loop again cool so
for request animation frame obviously
there's a module for that
there's a motor for everything
everything you might possibly want
and this is an example where like if we
had used jquery jquery doesn't really
have a way of doing request animation
frame out of the box
so you're going to need to have either
your own code or a module for that
anyway
um and i'm too lazy to write render so
i'm going to copy and paste it over here
and this one uses yet another module for
setting star properties
because i don't want to remember the
differences between
what the dom does and what the html does
because that's well
what the dom does and what css does
that's pin yes and now if we bundle this
again
go over here and refresh this um clearly
you've seen that i've hard coded oh you
can't see anything
clearly you've seen that i've hardcoded
the styling for this thing to
not fit more than 10 characters but
other than that
it looks it looks great
okay so that's kind of an example of the
workflow you go and search what you want
you pick the small things you want
it works great now however for me
personally
i don't want to work with that kind of
granularity all the time
that granularity is fine if i want to do
anything performance sensitive
but i've had enough of touching the dom
so let's step back a bit and talk about
some of the advantages of offering small
modules
if you offer a small thing
in theory hopefully people are going to
be able to reuse it and expand upon it
and collaborate with you i've actually
run into multiple situations in the past
where i've built like a like a
medium-sized thing
and i've tried to collaborate with
people and they said i
that thing's too big i don't want to
touch it like i i've personally seen
the
the way to put it is that people
don't want to collaborate on things that
aren't just absolute minimum subset they
want to collaborate on
they want to be able to
it's a lot easier to work with people if
you if you're as unpainted as possible
if you're trying to write like one small
thing that does one thing well
people can work with you on that if you
put that thing into a larger thing
you're going to start adding baggage
you're going to start adding opinion to
it
and people don't want to work with you
on that anymore
i wrote a module called xhr it's really
boring it sends http requests
i wrote it because i9 does course really
terribly
and i couldn't find anything else that
could do that now one of the cool things
about this is that other people have
built stuff on top of it
somebody built this library called http
and it basically takes mikhail's request
on the server
and actually shows on the client and
then gives it the same interface so you
can use the same code on both sides
he also added a couple of features i
forgot in xhr
like form encoding another guy
built a little thing on top of my thing
for doing
json by default out of the box and also
adding promise support
so my accusar module is just different
by a normal callback
because it's driven by a normal callback
it's pretty easy to add from support on
top
during the universe is a bit harder so
like he's able to not have to duplicate
my code just add promises
you can just add a thing on top and then
obviously there's other like people
using your stuff
if you write an xhr module the internet
sucks okay
someone's written a javascript client
for a flat sheet surface
and rather than using xml http requests
directly use one of my modules
so the idea here is that
if you can write small things people can
use them people can collaborate on that
and people can build on top of it
and as you get more when people bulldog
on top of a shared basis
everybody wins like it's code reuse
everybody everybody's happy
so the next concept i'm going to talk
about
is building a modular framework
and when i say framework here i want to
like have a quick aside
on separating
the implementation of a front-end
framework from the concept
the philosophy and the ideologies
a lot of those times those two pieces
are put together into one package
the most important thing about a
framework and the thing that's really
hard
and you should avoid doing this at all
cost even though i'm doing it myself and
i'm a terrible person
is to not write your own philosophy to
not write your own
top level concept of how to build
applications
how to structure them together and how
to
make them gel however
once you've taken some of these concepts
let's say let's say for example we take
reacts flux concept or we take
elms frp concept
it is possible to have
multiple implementations of a concept
so with react's flux it's all about
having union directional flow
from user input to like managing a state
to rendering
that's a great concept however it
shouldn't need to be coupled to any
implication detail
and people can differ slightly on their
choices implementation for that
so the advantage of differing on the
implementation
is that everybody can agree
on like the top level concepts and how
to structure application how things fit
together
but they can disagree on whether they
should use promises or callbacks
internally
or they can disagree on whether you
should trust
the things in an oop fashion or fp
fashion
like the the top level design shouldn't
be coupled to that
so if we want to
build our own implementation of one of
these concepts
ideally we can take a whole bunch of
modules together
and have them work well and once we do
that
it means that the next guy that comes
along and has slightly different ideas
can go and reuse half those modules he
doesn't have to go and
rewrite everything which seems to be
really common
in the front-end world well javascript
in general were terrible
at rewriting everything
and i had this personally i tried to use
a subset
of react myself specifically that
virtual domination
and i could not figure out where it was
in the impetition
i spent a lot of time looking back to
source code and i couldn't make
hello day out of it so
i wish that would have been written
modular from the ground up i wish react
was already modular so i didn't have to
go and
like i feel like a terrible person every
single time i solve an already solved
problem
so going back to this slide
the biggest thing about making sure that
the tooling and the framework you use as
modular is
to decompose your problem space
to decompose what you want to build into
reasonable pieces
i learned to work from the ground up and
the most important
part actually is to make sure every
single piece you write
is useful on its own it has to like
actually be a thing all if you want to
use
if you just take your big thing or
spread it out into five smaller things
but each individual thing doesn't make
any sense at all
without the others then
it means a lot of people can't use it it
means other people can build on top of
it and that's the thing we want we want
people to be able to
build on top of each other and to share
code
yeah so
as an example of how i went through and
tried to do this approach myself i
wanted to implement something
that had a unidirectional philosophy
behind it
i didn't invent this philosophy myself i
didn't like
come to i didn't wake up one morning and
decide like this is how we're going to
do stuff
i spent a lot of time reading react home
elm literature about how does this
approach should work
and this is kind of important like
whenever you're going to
grab together modules ideally you want
to
build on top of what other people have
done before
now this the part that sucks is i
couldn't find
small modules that do it that did what i
wanted and when i did find some
i had to re-implement them for really
small implication details
which kind of sucked but
that's okay because
i can use the things i want to use and
that people can use yellow ones
it's it's okay to have different
implementations it's okay to have
different trade-offs when i went and
decomposed
my solution i wanted to just build a
representation of my state
where i can be notified of changes and i
needed to be immutable for performance
reasons
so i built a thing for being notified of
changes
something that's observable and then i
built
two immutable an immutable object in the
meatball array
module and
i had a strong focus on making sure each
one of these was
useful on its own and i separated them
out to try and reduce complexity
apparently influencing an immutable
array is really really hard
and i was really complex however the
other two were a lot simpler
so i'm happy with the outcome of
isolating complexity in like the complex
module
and breaking out some simpler modules
um i needed a way to represent input
thankfully i'd written some modules a
year ago out of frustration with
other stuff i was doing and i could use
half of them
um i wrote a module for
handling reading of user input out of
the dom
so whenever user interaction happens i
just want to be able to say like
when the submit action happens give me
all the state in this form
and i wrote this module so that i would
work
with the dom interface it just returns
you an event listener
you can just element add event listener
the thing
and it works great standalone
and i'm really happy with being able to
build something that actually works
standalone so in theory other people can
go and use it
um we also had to implement some stuff
for the rendering side
um i really i tried really hard to use
react implementation
but it was pretty tightly coupled
one of the things i wanted with the
rendering of my view
was to be able to say
here's the stadium application and
here's what it should look like
so it's the exact same philosophy behind
reacts virtual dom
you just want to say what it would look
like so i built a module for
representing the virtual tree
i built a module for doing all the dom
manipulation which is which was
pain yes and then i built a separate one
for just
some syntax sugar because creating a
tree by hand without something
equivalent of jsx is a bit for both
now the interesting part here is these
pieces come together
to build a unidirectional style
application but every single one of
these pieces is an invitation detail
none of them are actually important to
be able to build the application with
the philosophy you want with the
architecture you want which means if you
don't agree about invitation details
that's okay we can still agree about the
architecture we can still agree about
how you build applications and you
should build alternatives
like it's really healthy to have
alternatives if we don't have
competition we're never going to like
build the best thing
we need competition for performance
reasons
um so one of the things i mentioned
earlier was you could publish ui
components as modules
and it's possible to just
zoom zoom zoom it's possible to just
publish some kind of widget with your
implementation details of choice
to your package manager choice and to
use it
so this is going to render a little
widget
document body pin chant
and it's going to show somebody's name
does somebody want to give me a name on
github
okay i will pick my name because nobody
shouted loud enough
so as on the side require bonus is
really cool tool for playing around with
npm
you can just write common jazz and write
npm style stuff
and you click rebuild and it works
so on the right you can see the default
assets right we've
included some widget over the internet
we had the one line install we had the
oneline require
it comes with all the css and the icons
and the blah blah blah blah blah
the important thing here is
you can publish all of this to mpm and
it will just work
and also this widget actually
implementation detail
uses like my framework and all of my
all of the stuff i personally like and i
export
a dom based interface so other people
can use it
and that will work quite cleanly
so the last time i wanted this show was
building one of these uninteractional
apps with modules
and in fact the important part of the
demo i wanted to show because i'm really
low on time
was that whatever you use as an
invitation needle
so the important thing about
a unity direction let's actually show
what this looks like browser file
demo to list
ah piping index modified
to do
so i have a little demo for an app it's
really stupid
you write some text and you read some
stuff
and you add a thing and it works cool
so the way i represented this was i
wanted to say what user input is
like this add event i wanted to say what
the state was
which in this particular case is some
text up here and a list of things
and then i wanted to handle user
interaction
on addition let's push a new thing into
the array
and then rendering like i have some
rendering code
um which if you screen really really
hard
it looks just like jade and you can you
can pretend it's not
the you can pretend there's no braces
it's really not that bad
um render a list preach one of the item
we render a thing
and we render form over here
really not that exciting but the
interesting thing here is
if i don't like the implication detail
of
what i choose for the state i can just
get rid of it
and i can swap out for a better module
it turns out there was a bug in it or
like i just don't like reynolds and its
code
and i want to replace the backbone
so
you can implement an app with the same
philosophy and different
different modules so we want nope not
that
we want okay i'm just going to cheat a
bit more
we want this stuff
so here all i'm doing is i'm refactoring
my code to use backbone models
and backbone collections and i have
another model for the application state
has the exact same description and array
of events and i set it up over here
and then i'm not even gonna
bother running that one but i will run
the other one
that and
no that won't work this will work
now let's open that
so this one is the exact same partition
exact same rendering logic
and it's using back one of the model
layer
so one of the kind of important parts
of using modules and the thing that we
really want is to be able to swap out
an entire entire subsection of our
application
with different competition and this will
be really difficult to achieve
if you're using some kind of
tightly coupled npc framework
and i believe that's all about all i
have time for thank you
so
you